bookings have been staggered over to
sittings so we'll be working for six
hours straight after Zach's performance
with the chowder I put him on bar duty
Kim Nick Richard and Peter we work in
the floor Andy's in charge of the
kitchen with Ave
how many is it how many is the chicken
forward four
I'm an executive chef well yeah he's in
charge of crockery okay you've got three
Champa's up there
they made place burger tastes brilliant
will do NIC the world are good to me
some customers the burgers are selling
well but at the moment not enough
chicken just two or three if you want
the chicken we will bring out your table
and : for your table it's not one to try
Thank You sell one chicken the best the
dying will start to see it's a little
bit of excitement a little bit of magic
happening around the table so the
long-stalled ring which then within an
hour or an hour which is exactly you
need it's a nice buzz coming out of room
sounds really happy here we can do it
after all my doubts
it's Peter who solved the first chicken
spring chicken that's not sure enough
soon everyone wants one
throughout you become disabled
everybody's rising to the occasion and
the first sittings going really well
- it's great to see the dining room full
and feel the buzz